um well first of all let me say it's not
every day that i like networking there
are days that i just think i would
rather
chop off my arm than have to go to that
thing tonight and i've tried to sort of
recognize you know you can overdo that
stuff
um i think that to me a lot of it
revolves around context find a context
it's a it's really hard to just walk
into a cocktail party and start going
around and shaking the hands of all the
people
i can never be a politician that just
that just freaks me out that they would
go do that that would be horrible but i
think if you're involved in a charitable
organization if you're involved in a
a trade association
a lot of my contacts came from my work
with the software publishers association
and now with the national venture
capital association because you have
context you have a reason to meet with
people you know it depends on the
context and i think that for those of
you who sort of cringe at the thought
of doing that
um you will find it a lot easier if it's
if it the smaller the group and the more
meaningful the context is to you i think
the easier it is and build a network
over time it doesn't take you know sure
i have a huge network i'm gonna be 50
next year i mean that you know it took
it took a long time to build that
network um i don't think you can expect
that you're going to suddenly have this
network of
of super important people i mean the
other thing about it is not all those
people were that important when i first
met them
you know it's they may be important now
but they weren't that important back
then
neither was i i'm probably still not but
yeah i'm working on it but you know
sometimes it's you meet people in a
particular context and you all grow
together as a group around that context
and then those relationships become
incredibly powerful they didn't start
out that way
what's the um best advice you can give
for managing time
when i got to business school here there
was a class taught by
michael ray called creativity and
business i don't know if he's still
teaching he wrote a book i don't know if
he's still teaching around here or
anything probably not
um but he had this interesting class and
one of the elements he taught was you
had to spend this week you almost had to
spend a week doing something and there's
this week called do only that which is
easy effortless and enjoyable which is a
little hard in the context of being a
second year student at the business
school frankly
but what i realized and my takeaway from
that week which has stayed with me all
this time is sometimes you're just more
in the mood to do certain things than
other things
and
people laugh about my time management
well one of the reasons i don't have a
secretary and i do all my own scheduling
and all that is i like to manage around
what i feel like doing at different
hours of the day and i like to manage
around wardrobe
like some days i want to wear sweats all
days and some days i want to do the
whole power suit thing
and i don't want to have to change
during the day so i mean if i told
somebody like a secretary hi you're my
new secretary look there are suit days
and there are sweats days and on sweats
days i only take these kind of meetings
and on suit days and they think i'm i
was crazy right but the reality is you
can be a lot more efficient when you can
group together
some days i talk on the phone other days
i do big blocks of email
someday some weeks i travel sometimes i
don't travel and over time you get
really efficient at sort of figuring out
how to group things together admittedly
the nice thing about being a venture
capitalist is people do tend to sort of
bend to your schedule you know if you
were a corporate executive it would be
very hard to say to your boss oh today's
not a suit day i can't possibly meet
with that customer i'm in sweats today
um you know that wouldn't work very well
but i think that's part of why i picked
the job i picked is is that i is that i
do that i use a lot of technology and i
delegate a lot too i mean you can't do
you just can't do all that stuff and
then and then my husband says i also
just lower my standards like you know if
you come to my house for dinner
it's probably p you know pizza from
round table and a salad or if it's pasta
you either have to make it or you're
going to have to clean it up so you know
there were there were some students here
last year and and i was speaking in a
class and about seven when we came up
after the class and they said to me we'd
really like to meet with you again we
really want to explore some issues and
they were really nice about they said
can we take you to dinner i said i don't
really like going out to dinner i like
being around my kids but if you want to
bring chinese food over to my house and
clean up after yourselves you can do
that and so we did that and it was
really fun so i think there are ways you
can you sort of
you sort of make things work and you
kind of get creative about how you
manage your own time
um you know at the end of the day the
bottom line too is to prioritize there
are just times you have to say no
and that's the hardest thing for me to
do it's that student on a sunday who
wants 15 minutes
you know you just can't do that for
every student who contacts you and that
is that's the hardest thing i mean if i
could do that all day that's super fun
but that isn't i just can only have so
much time for those sorts of things
so that's a good segue into this next
question which says
why do you spend so much time emailing
entrepreneurs whose business plans
you're outright rejecting considering
you've little to gain from those
interactions and little time to maintain
more productive relationships
um well first of
all uh you never know which one's going
to be productive or not productive
and i think that's one of the beauties
and challenges about this environment
that we live in is that anyone
might be a great entrepreneur they might
be a great entrepreneur today they might
be a great entrepreneur three years from
now you know i joke about this if sergey
and larry had like come to me i would
have said search it's already been done
you know i'm not gonna go there if you
know if the i can't remember the
facebook guy's name you guys whoever
isn't you know oh shoot he's a harvard
dropout you know he's not he hasn't even
graduated from college yet you know are
you really going to look at his deal i
mean the thing is so wonderful is
there's a lot of
there are a lot of fabulous
entrepreneurs who who are brand new and
who are breaking the rules and making
new rules and i don't know who those
people are going to be so if you have a
if if you just always have a i think a
courteous and professional
front to people people remember that and
again there are you know
i emailed some really high level guy at
google a couple years ago and i said it
was kind of like a cold call email i
said i just would really like to meet
you and talk to you about what you're
doing um in this space and it turned out
he had been a student at the business
school and had come to a time i taught
my case and so again that 50 you know
i'm like the katherine mcphee of that
but for him he was an american idol
watcher so it was okay you know it was
like hey yeah i'll take a meeting with
you heidi i i i remember when you spoke
at my class and you know that happens
sometimes and so
you know part of why you do stuff like
this or meeting with entrepreneurs is
because that is my job and i am
prospecting and you got to kiss a lot of
frogs to find the right thing and
sometimes it's just a good will creation
that i think comes back and
and you know comes back and and
hopefully brings benefit in the future
and kind of creates general goodwill
there are times you just don't respond i
mean that you know unfortunately
because of the nature of our business
sometimes you turn people down for
reasons they don't want to hear
and sometimes it's not in your best
interest to tell them
um and you don't have to you know i can
just say no i can just say it was a bad
day i mean i was talking to somebody
this morning i did a podcast this
morning i said you know what happens if
you just have a meeting with the
entrepreneur and you just can't stand
the person
some people can work with people that
can't stand i have a hard time doing
that and so if i find the person
annoying and grating and offensive i'm
probably going to turn them down am i
going to say
i find you annoying that's why i'm
turning you down i mean i don't
probably not you know so sometimes you
just say no and you just
try to make people go away
i haven't figured out a perfect way to
do that right now
is there a really good way to reject
someone
yeah you say i love this deal but my
partner is just i can't get it
that's the best way
and uh and we we laugh about that
because that is sort of you know it is a
partnership and you do have team dynamic
um
so i think the honest you know if you
value the person if somebody comes in
and they say i'm thinking about this
idea i like saying to people
look
there's a hundred of these out there and
you gotta tell me why you're different
so i if i can give them constructive
advice and if i feel like the person is
listening
then i will go that extra mile
particularly if their friend if there's
someone i've done business with before
if they're just starting out you know
whatever it's remarkable to me how many
times people just don't want to hear it
and so if they don't want to hear it you
can kind of sense that and by the end of
the meeting you just say hey you know
don't take offense but this isn't a deal
for me and i think that's the thing that
people also they don't
realize
is when you're pitching your deal
it's not like interviewing for a job
when you're interviewing for a job
there's an identified job they're
probably going to interview 15 20 people
and somebody's going to get that job
when you're pitching a deal
you're pitching to a person who looks at
200 deals a year 300 deals a year and is
going to maybe do one or two or none
they're not compelled to do any if they
don't find something that's interesting
to them
and there is no defined deadline by
which they need to do that deal if any
so the problem is
i think most people when they start
pitching their ventures they think it's
like interviewing for a job and you
either should get the job or told why
you're not getting it or somebody should
get the job and maybe you go through 10
interviews before you get a job in
venture you might pitch 50 or 100 times
before you get a vc or never and you
have to be ready for that and so
what i really respect is if i turn
somebody down they email me back and
they say i get it i really appreciate
your time could you give me three things
i could improve upon you know what were
the three things that really struck you
as bad
the worst thing there are two bad ways
to to respond to rejection right one is
to not respond at all and it's amazing
to me how many entrepreneurs
i don't know what it is you spend i mean
i'm spending time too i'm spending six
seven eight nine ten hours trying to get
to know the deal and at the end i send
him a note i say i'm sorry this deal you
know just isn't going to work out for me
at least if someone said well i
appreciate your time
why why wouldn't you spend the two
seconds to kind of close the loop in a
courteous manner or they want to come
back and argue with you well you're
wrong you're wrong about that
i'm like and and when they do that you
just say great i you know
the last thing in the world the last
thing the world needs is for another
failed entrepreneur to exist so i hope i
hope you prove me wrong i hope you go
out and make a kajillion bazillion
dollars and satisfy this market need
because
i'd be happier the world will be a
happier place if you do that if you
don't but it is i mean that it is
it's it people people don't like to be
rejected and and unfortunately in my
business you're saying no
99.5 percent of the time if not more
um
i actually find it liberating right now
because i'm saying no 100 percent of the
time because i don't i we've exited our
investment period so i'm not doing any
investing and it's in a really funny way
i'm trying to stay in the deal flow
business and i get a lot of deal flow so
i say to entrepreneurs i'm not funding
anything right now if you want to come
spend an hour
i'll listen and i'll give you my
feedback
and um and if i think it's worthy of if
i think it would be something i would
have done i'll kick it over to one of my
other vc buddies and but no guarantees
right zero and that's actually been
really comforting because i just there's
nothing i can do anyway so i think it's
gonna get boring after a little while
but right now it's actually kind of fun
to just say and it's interesting to say
if somebody says i just want your
feedback and you say well i can't give
you any money but i'll give you my
feedback and then all of a sudden your
feedback's not that interesting anymore
um but some of them still want your
feedback and and it's been kind of fun
and two of the deals that i've done that
for in the last six months
both look like they're going to get term
sheets from the guys i referred them to
so again it's like what what am i being
paid for that i'm being paid zero
but next year if and when i either raise
a new fund or go out to join another
firm and they say well what the hell
were you doing the last year where you
weren't doing any deals i can say well
look these two deals got funded because
i made you know i helped these
entrepreneurs and
so
i guess i'm still good at finding deals
even if i didn't do it myself
this question is when you started your
career early on like many of us i
imagine you didn't have much to offer
senior people so how do you establish
reciprocity with those higher status
contacts that tend to be more valuable
it's interesting this question comes up
a lot
and i always find it
it's kind of funny in the way that we
all have to start somewhere
and
my own belief is everybody's got
something to offer you have to pick the
right person you're going to offer to
and you have to figure out what that
person needs
and so
um
there are there are literally people who
have traded me there was a student at
the gsb here once a couple years ago who
wanted some of my time on something and
he was a personal trainer and he said
i'll train you
and he did and he worked with me for a
couple months and the deal was you know
i would talk if i could well well he was
training me and that worked you know
there are you know again i think it's
about context if you want to get to know
somebody
volunteer for a project they care about
you know almost in fact the interesting
thing is almost every sort of
high-powered person you know you go look
at the venture capitalists and go look
at their bios or go look at the ceos and
look at their bios they're all on some
non-profit board they're all on some
politic they're politically affiliated
they're all involved with schools or
something get involved in one of those
organizations it's a great way to meet
people and contribute that way and again
i think that this is the thing about
you're building
an asset over time and you cannot expect
that those pay out the first time you
meet somebody and so you can't meet
someone and the next week ask them for
something
um and you know i still feel that way
i'm i'm really sensitive about asking
people for help although you know i need
help too and i ask people for help but i
always
again i don't keep a register i don't
have a database of you know who owes me
favors versus who do i owe favors to but
i kind of a general sense of if i'm
going to ask somebody for something
there has to be either value in them
even in the request i'm making or
in some collective amount of stuff i've
done for them beforehand so i just think
don't limit yourself be creative you
know you can you can walk somebody's dog
you can house it for them you can
babysit for them you can do all sorts of
crazy things that get you in touch with
people i personally believe the
organizing around either professional
organization or charitable organization
and going in and volunteering where that
organization has collected people that
you're interested in is is pretty much
the best way to do it
so
um a lot of students want to know what
you thought about the internet
networking sites and do you use them
and some of them want to know if you'll
add them to your
yeah no um no i don't
i i have a i have a pretty funny story
of that actually i don't remember i
think it was it wasn't linkedin but it
was probably friendster where one day i
got this thing and it said bill gates
has asked you to you know to like link
up with him or something so i just you
know i deleted it because i was like
that's so not bill gates um
and then i saw him a few weeks later and
i was talking to him and i and i said
something about oh yeah you know i got
that email from you and he goes
god i know i can't believe you didn't
add me to your network
i said that was really from you and he
goes of course it wasn't for me but i
had that moment where i'm like oh god i
didn't add bill gates to my network but
anyway it wasn't him he was just pulling
my leg but um you know i think i think
that i think they're a really
interesting phenomenon and i think they
are very um
generationally specific
and i think that's the challenge is i am
i am really old and old-fashioned and
like my kids are like mom you don't use
text messaging you don't use i am you
are so email god that's so old nobody
uses email right but i use email i don't
i mean i struggle through texting and
and i aming and all that stuff it's just
not the way i like to operate where my
kids do that totally all the time
um you know they have 17 different email
addresses i'm like i have a hard time
remembering too and so it's just a
different it's a generational thing and
i think things like you know for example
linkedin
i pulled myself off of linkedin because
the problem is all the favors were only
flowing in one direction and i wasn't
using it myself i just kind of you know
and maybe i'm just
kind of built my network the
old-fashioned way and just i've got my
life working in that way and so i use
email i use you know i pick up the phone
and call people i find who i need
through
i google a lot of stuff so i do use
current tools you know i'm not using
like the telegraph and smoke signals
anymore but
but i use the things i'm comfortable
with and it's probably not the same way
my kids would do things
and um i think those sites can be very
interesting i certainly think you know
on on i gotta say on the dating front i
have friends who've met their soul mates
on you know these various sites and have
gotten married and i think it's pretty
cool um
i don't know about business my feeling
about this stuff is when you get
something that's more than
two degrees of separation
it's kind of like who cares i mean
everybody in fact my nephew argues that
everybody is six degrees of separation
from everybody else anyway so it's like
they're that in fact i think they did
some study right where you can find
somebody you you know pretty depending
on your connections you can always find
somebody so i just don't i think those
sites have a lot of i think they're very
interesting
i have not been able to apply them to my
own life
because they don't work for me in a
business context and
i've been married for 17 years so i
missed out on all that but
i'll let you know if that changed
um
just one question uh it's pretty
interesting have you ever contacted
somebody who wasn't interested in
networking with you but was important
for you to develop a relationship with
if so what did you do to try to develop
that relationship anyway yeah that's
that's a great question i'm pretty
fearless um about trying to get in touch
with people
and um and people are remarkably
responsive
and i don't know if it's because you
know in silicon valley a little bit it's
because i have enough you know
brand to my name that i can you know
i'll i sort of i presume
this is going to sound terribly
conceited and i don't mean it this way
oh it sounds bad i'll say it anyway i i
can kind of presume that after living in
this valley as long as i have and doing
all the things i haven't been president
of the traders and blah blah blah that
like and i have an unusual name that
people will probably have heard of me
anybody i want to get in touch with has
probably already heard of me they may
not know me they may not know anything
about me but they've probably seen my
name in some context of something and so
a lot of times i just pretend like i
already know them
and i just i don't say hey
remember that time we spent on the lake
or something like i mean i'm not like
that but but i'll just send an email and
say
hey so-and-so
um i hope you don't mind me contacting
you but i gotta really i don't start
with you probably don't know me but i'm
blah blah blah i'm gonna presume they do
know me if they don't know me the first
thing they're gonna do what's the first
thing you do if you get an email from
someone you're not sure if you know them
or not you google them well you can
google me i have tons of you know
there's lots of stuff on the web not all
of it that i like but so they're gonna
figure out who i am in five seconds and
they're gonna determine either they're
gonna respond to me or not
and sometimes they don't respond if they
don't respond i try emailing them again
and if they still don't respond i either
give up or i try going through another
context i will almost always use a
friend you know as a as a conduit
because it's a lot easier to say hey you
know heidi wants to talk to you but is
it okay but it's just remarkable and
again the beauty of of today is everyone
is so accessible
and i um
you can guess people's email addresses
and nine times out of ten you're right
right and so
um it's pretty easy to get in touch with
people and and again i'm not i'm not
like a stalker if i email them and they
don't email me back i drop it you know
or if if they just say no that's fine
i'm not afraid
so your network is really clearly very
strong in silicon valley and some
students were interested in with india
and china becoming more important in
tech and how have you
changed or you know enlarged your
network outside of silicon valley that's
that's an interesting question and
that's a trade-off and i think that's
one that you all have to think about you
know where you are in your careers
um i really think that um
i mean clearly the world is is
going elsewhere i don't think that
neither silicon valley nor america can
continue to be sort of the superpower
they want we're that said i think that
we will continue both silicon valley and
america will continue to play a hugely
important role in so many different um
ecosystems and and and um economies and
and
markets that from a business perspective
i've sort of said hey there's lots of
people
who are going to be great at
specializing in china or india or
whatever people inherently have
advantages like they came from there
they speak the language i don't have
those and so just like i decided many
years ago that i didn't have a technical
undergrad degree and therefore i was not
going to be an engineer and it was too
late for me and and to this day i don't
do really deep tech investing because
it's just it's just not there i'd be a
c-plus at that you know pick people who
are a's at that stuff so
i i try to be very open to
um understanding the implications of of
china india and other countries and
their rise i certainly every one of my
companies does business in those
countries has employees in those
countries but am i suddenly gonna
you know get on the nerd bird and fly
over to shanghai and invest money no i
mean i think that would be foolish of me
to do that so
i think that you know and again this is
very different when you're sitting here
and you're and you're 48 versus when
you're sitting out there and you're 28
or younger or older
within that range is at this point i'm
kind of i'm pretty baked right i am who
i am i've got my strengths i've got my
weaknesses i've got i i try to be pretty
self-aware about what i like to do and
what i don't like to do
so
i'm not going to uproot my family and
move to shanghai
one of my partners did you know he's got
a chinese wife and he he wants his kids
to learn to speak chinese and he moved
there i'm not going to do that and so
i have to figure out how to how to be
uniquely
to ex exploit what is what are my
competencies to do the things that fit
in the environment i want to be in and
not necessarily adapt myself to other
places so if that sounds too insular and
old-fashioned and you know like i'm
throwing in the towel to you guys i will
also say that
i have to learn new skills all the time
right so there are things that i decided
i did want to learn like a couple of
years ago
there were some companies i was
interested in and they were ad supported
models and i really had not been in a
business that was ad supported in the
past and i thought i got to learn this
business i got to learn about dmas and
cpms and and i got to learn about you
know
arbitron and and all that stuff so i can
speak the language of ad supported
models
and now i know a lot about ad supported
models so it isn't that i'm saying i
don't want to learn anything new or meet
anyone new for the rest of my life but i
just think that there are places where
you can expand your skill set and there
are other places you can say
i'm only going to be a c player in that
what role do you think gender plays in
your networking
and as it turns out we actually have
some some information about this aside
from what heidi may say in terms of a
commentary does gender matter
does the fact that you're a woman affect
your networking or does the
does the fact you're a woman affect the
way in which you network
i guess i'm struck by the fact that when
i go look at heidi's website for mobius
and i don't know if you can see this
very well
but this is the picture of the
partnership team and can you guess which
one heidi is um
there's only one woman there in that
picture uh so she actually works in a
field that seems pretty gender
concentrated um and the concentration
not being women and so as it turns out
heidi mentioned the case was written by
a woman at harvard named kathleen mcginn
who i knew
and contacted emailed her and asked her
if i could have the original case itself
and when she agreed to give me the
original case i took it and then changed
it
to howard royson
and changed the pronouns in the case
from she to he and from her to him
and then gave two sections of the same
class the same case except one section
had the heidi version of the case the
original and the other section had the
howard version of the case and they had
no idea that there were two different
versions on the syllabus it was only
listed as roizen instead of the heidi
reisen case
and so before class the students were
asked to go online and rate their
impressions of roisin what they thought
of rosin before coming to talk about
roisin in class
and they're asked to rate roy's in a
number of different dimensions some
positive dimensions some negative
dimensions how confident or effective
they thought roisin was and whether or
not they liked rosin wanted to hire
roy's and would want to work with royzen
et cetera
so
heidi's seen all this before but some of
the items were how genuine do you think
royson is how humble do you think royson
is and how kind do you think royzen is
and as it turns out
these are these are wildly statistically
significant differences um
big differences between the howard
version of the case the students who
read the howard version of the case and
the students who read the heidi version
of the case and those students who read
the heidi version the case thought that
heidi was less genuine less humble less
kind than those students who read the
howard version of the case
and when they responded items like how
power hungry how self-promoting
how disingenuous do you think roizen is
the students who read the heidi version
of the case gave much stronger responses
to that item than the students who read
this is the hard part about being the
subject of a case by the way
so i apologize for that
um
and then the interesting question is
what about the items assessing
competence or effectiveness
well here students saw no difference at
all no discernible difference between
heidi and howard it wasn't that they
thought heidi was less competent or less
effective than howard it was just that
they didn't like heidi very much
compared to howard
they wouldn't want to hire her and they
certainly wouldn't enjoy working with
her compared with howard
um
and what really drove these differences
tended to be this agentic or assertive
personal difference or personality
the more aggressive or assertive they
thought heidi was the more the students
disapproved in fact that's where all the
action is in these uh ratings but when
they're they're seeing heidi or howard
as less assertive they don't gender
doesn't really matter
and so one i think there's a number of
questions students probably have but
i'll actually give heidi a chance to
talk about this uh since um you know we
planned on having some discussion about
it today
uh well one of the interesting is i
don't know if you have the data but can
you show the split oh yeah
the male respondents and the female
responders so this is um the first
question in fact there were a few hands
that went up and i'm betting that at
least one of those hands one had asked
this question which was did you cut it
by rate or sex and as it turned out when
i emailed heidi about these results that
was the first thing she emailed back to
me was did you cut it by raider sex
and i did i actually should say i did
this with a colleague of mine at nyu
cameron anderson this study
and we did cut it by raider sex and
as it turns out all of the
differences
were driven by one sex who were reading
the case
and the other sex really saw no
difference between heidi and howard
whatsoever they gave the same ratings
for both
but all the action was in one sex so i
asked my class
there were 90 students
and i asked them who do you think
did all the discriminating or that sort
of saw the differences between heidi and
howard and out of 90 students 86 of them
all said
what do you think
sure they all said it was the women
it was the men
and now
think about how screwed up that is on so
many levels because not only are women
obviously the victim of stereotyping in
this case but they're also being blamed
for doing the stereotyping they're not
doing
to themselves
so that's pretty messed up and i have to
admit heidi i should mention the rest of
heidi's email was did you cut it by
raider sex it was the women wasn't it
yeah
i did say that so i was thinking about
this case and i was thinking
when you read when i read the case the
problem is i'm too close to it so when i
read the case it's just me and they're
they're a thing but there are probably
things i do that are very
female gender identity and identified
right sending cards and flowers and cute
stuff like that and then there are
things i probably do that are very male
gender identified like the like my
comment about i'll just send an email
and and presume you know me and if you
don't you'll be too embarrassed to admit
you don't know me and you'll probably
respond that's a very i think that's a
very male thing to do so what i'm
wondering about is if you read the case
and you think it's a male
maybe what you do is you forgive him in
his aggressive behavior and you decide
that man that dude's really in touch
with his feminine side you know he sends
flowers or he writes people these nice
notes and isn't that great and i like
that guy because he's like that where if
you're a man and you read the stuff
about and it's a woman
you don't like the fact
that a woman is aggressive that a woman
is you know and and i can't remember you
know because i haven't read the case in
a while i don't i don't remember how
much that comes through but i'm just
wondering if
i don't know that's that's this week's
theory that i have on this oh absolutely
there certainly is
um
certainly is a likelihood that a
man who is viewed as the being in touch
in the feminine side might be seen
possibly as a sensitive new age guy yeah
um but a woman who acts more assertively
maybe incur some backlash for having
violated that feminine gender stereotype
and certainly that seems to be what
drives this uh difference
that even though there's no difference
in the content of the case whatsoever
and only a difference in terms of the
ascribed sex or the inferred gender um
you know that the differences are pretty
i have to admit i actually thought about
it i've never read the case with howard
but i think i should because you know
like the part where i'm in the bathroom
bathing my children i'm thinking howard
would be in a bathroom bathing with
children with a female friend sitting in
the bathroom
the only thing we changed in the case
and no student mentioned that actually
uh and the howard royson version is now
available from harvard because a lot of
people are running this uh in their
classes um
but the uh um the one that we did change
was we did change cheerleader to
football players okay we weren't sure if
that would you know we
this has become something funny at home
because once in a while if i have a
tough thing at work and i'm talking to
my husband out he goes yeah maybe
tomorrow you should send howard
your doppelganger you mentioned one
point you like to connect people when
you see that as a mutual it's beneficial
for both parties and that that obviously
makes a lot of sense what do you do when
you have
let's take the following case you have a
friend who comes to you and says i
really want you to put me in touch with
one of your contacts who's clearly not
as good of a friend yeah and this person
needs to see that person for a job or
needs a favor
and then your contact you know it's
gonna be a waste of their time yeah um
but you don't wanna tell your friend no
you don't waste your contacts time
because next time they're going to not
want to see who you're introducing right
how do you deal with that situation
there are two ways to deal with that um
great question one way is you tell your
friend no
and there are some things i just tell my
you know there
so many people want me to just
to contact bill and melinda gates about
something and i don't care how good the
charity is i don't care how great the
need is i don't care i just don't do
that and so i i will say to friends hey
you know my husband's the president of a
charity and we don't even ask bill
melinda ever for that because
one of the one of the reasons i think i
can maintain a friendship with them is
because i've set boundaries on
on what i think is appropriate and they
get inundated with that kind of stuff
right
um so i just say absolutely not i don't
do it i don't introduce anyone and i
don't even um in fact there's this kind
of funny story about we were actually
selling a company to microsoft last year
last year the year before and i was
really mad at the way corp debit
microsoft was handling it
and i almost picked up the phone and
called bill about it but i'm thinking
god what a way i'm not going to do that
you know i'm going to deal with my
issues through microsoft corp dev i'm
i'm really angry about this but i'm
certainly not going to
use my friendship with bill
to um
to call to to do that
by the way something really funny
happened i i had said it to the ceo who
knows i know bill and i was like oh i
have half of mine to call bill i'm so
mad about this
and the ceo was like oh god please don't
do that so i was driving up the city
that night and i realized it was march
31st
right which meant the next day was april
1st
and um this ceo whom i've known for a
long time is a huge joke he loves to
play april fool's jokes so i got so
excited about this so i emailed bill on
my sidekick while i was driving which is
probably a bad idea but i was so excited
i said if i sent you an email
tonight after midnight
and asked it and and it's going to be
like a pretend email where i'm going to
be really trashed i'm going to send you
this email saying i've had five glasses
of wine and now i just want to tell you
how pissed off i am and i copy the ceo
and luckily bill knew the ceo they
they've met in the past
i said
it's a joke so if i do that would you
just if i write you a response will you
respond
and he did
so
i wrote this email and it said
you know we're doing this deal and you
know your guys are just being such jerks
and blah blah and you know why don't you
get your pitbulls off and you know the
you know you should be kissing our feet
that you know we're saving your ass in
this product line because your own team
couldn't deliver and you know i mean i
wrote this really scathing email
and i sent it to him and i and i sent it
to bill and i copied the ceo
who so like six o'clock in the morning i
could hardly go to bed it was like
christmas you know so
it's six o'clock in the morning the
phone rings and it's um
and i see because of thanks to caller id
i see it says ceo and i'm thinking
i'm not going to answer that phone you
know i just don't want to answer that
phone so i know his wife's cell phone
number so i called his wife on her cell
phone and i said i've just done this
really horrible thing
and and i'm going to not answer any of
my phone so if you need to reach me call
me on your cell phone because i'm not
gonna i said but could you please call
the cfo and let them know i did this
because literally the deal was supposed
to close that day so she called the cfo
who called the biz dev guy at microsoft
and let him in on the joke so then the
biz dev guy called up our ceo and said i
can't believe it what did you do i just
got a word from mr gates's office that
he wants the deal called off
and so
so then i had i had written a response
for bill to send me that just and and
because i've known for a long time
noah's writing style i was like god
heidi i can't believe you emailed me
this is the stupidest thing in the world
i can't believe you're wasting my time
and we didn't want that company anyway
you know i'm just trying to do you a
favor because i know your returns are so
bad after the dot-com bust and yeah blah
blah blah and and god i wish we had
implemented that breathalyzer feature in
outlook
which i love that line unfortunately
that's what tipped ceo off to the fact
that it was all fake
but um but anyway i really count that as
like my greatest april fool's joke ever
and i'm sorry that was way off topic but
i just i just love that story but the
point is that i even wouldn't have i
never would have contacted bill on that
i i believe the first line of defense is
i have to defend my relationships and so
you have to learn to say no and
sometimes you just have to say you know
the strongest thing and a lot of it has
to do with things like that would you
introduce me to this big powerful person
so i can ask them to donate money or do
something and the answer is no and you
know what i live by the same rule i
don't ask that person for that stuff on
my own behalf and therefore i'm not
going to ask them for you the second
thing though sometimes you know you
sometimes you get the person who says
hey i hear there's a job opening at
company xyz and you're on their board
and i think i'd be a great
fit would you please make an
introduction and you kind of know
they're not a great fit sometimes
they're a nice person they're just not
the right fit but you don't want to say
hey i already know you're not going to
get this job
so a lot of times i will send an email
to the ceo and i say i've got to make
this introduction it's a socially
correct thing to do i don't think this
person is a fit
um you know that i'm gonna send it to
you you're welcome to meet with them you
know but it but i'm not endorsing this
candidate
and you know that's what you got to do
and you know i hear some groans in there
you know it believe me i don't go back
to that person and say hey i put in a
big great word for you and i'm sure
you're going to get the job it's you
know it's a tepid response sure i'll be
happy to send it along so
um you know again it's it's a it's a big
spectrum and sometimes
you've got to say please don't touch
this person with a 10 foot pole you know
and and and that happens sometimes with
references i get called for references
on people blind references
and
that's one of the most delicate things
in the valley believe me you never put
that on an email or a voicemail or
whatever but you know if you ever email
someone and say hey i'm thinking of
somebody for a job
and i know they worked for you
um what can you tell me about them and
the response comes back it says call me
that's usually never good
it's like oh i'm unwilling to say
anything in an email that's usually bad
but you know that's a lot of the fabric
of what makes this valley work is
i can't let someone knowingly hire you
know some axe murderer if i like that
person and i know that person is an axe
murderer so you've got to be very
careful about that stuff though
hi
apparently you seem to tell people what
you think
do you sometimes feel like you need
to be a hypocrite to actually please
people yeah that was pretty hypocritical
what i just said wasn't it i mean again
it sounds bad y'all passed your resume
along when i'm also going around the
back door to that person saying i just
don't think this is going to be a fit
um and by the way once in a while
someone gets hired that i didn't think
was a fit so
you know there's a big difference
between a good person skill set but
they're just not right for this job
versus evil person
you know which frankly i try to diminish
my contact with those people or i'll all
you know i will say gee
the you know the job's been filled or
you know every once in a while i have a
really hard time with this but i'm
trying to learn to just hit the delete
key one of my partners has this big
issue with me because he says i am
incapable
of not responding
um i have to respond
and and he said sometimes you just have
to hit the delete key because he runs
this blog and he has all these readers
and they all respond and i say god how
do you keep up with the burden of just
having to respond to all those people he
said i don't i have a really hard time
you know i do and again it's one thing
that i find the most fascinating about
entrepreneurs is when they get an idea
very often they just don't want to go
out there and see
that it's already been done and so they
just go like this and they focus on
their thing and you go
try googling the following words and see
what comes up you know it's sort of
again it's remarkable that all that data
is out there and people don't use it so
you walk a fine line well you've talked
a lot about networking in the valley
here and i was wondering if you think
it's different for people from the east
coast or the midwest or if those
principal apply university
um
i think there are different cultures
around different industries
and this is the industry i know so this
one i think works in a very
community kind of social you know i
think it's interesting that we have such
a concentrated number of important
companies in the valley and such a place
where entrepreneurship is celebrated
here it's almost inevitable that there's
so much
networking that goes on in a certain way
and it's just such a fabric of the
valley to be in the technology business
that i think it works a certain way i
think you know la and hollywood work in
a really different way and i've had a
little bit of interaction there because
i have some projects down there that
involve sort of more the movie
television type and they're you know
it's all nobody does email or if they do
it's like three words long and it's all
about meetings and it's all about
lunches and it's all about i mean it's
just very different right so there is a
kind of a different context
um
and i'm like 25 years too old and four
sizes too big and i'm not a natural
blonde of course there aren't very many
natural ones down there either but you
know so it's like as a woman i
definitely feel
i definitely feel like a big old woman
when i go down to la to do deals as
opposed to here where it doesn't even
cross my mind you know i don't think
about
sort of that
aspect of of what i bring to the table
so i do think it is a little bit
different i certainly think in the
technology industry and i do try to meet
people outside the valley because i
think that one of the exciting things
about the technology industry is we do
touch so many other industries right now
and so i think in terms of media and
entertainment and all of that you do
need to get to know other people and i
do find sometimes the styles a little
bit different but
i think fundamental common human nature
and courtesy is sort of the same
everywhere i mean cult internationally
as well you know sometimes
internationally i've had issues it's not
in this case but one of the other cases
a story about when i went to japan
in the early 80s to do a contract and
they didn't want to deal with me because
they wanted to deal with men and i
wasn't a man and they want to deal with
my brother because he was the author of
the program but my brother didn't want
to
didn't want to travel and so there were
cultural issues that sometimes you say
well culturally i just can't win i
should have sent howard that day
but you know sometimes sometimes it
sometimes your style doesn't work and
and and and again maybe this sounds kind
of old and whatever but i'm kind of at
the point in my life where
i like the style of who i am
and not everybody's going to like me
which took me a long time i had like for
the first i don't know how many years of
my life i just thought everyone had to
like me and if you didn't like me my god
it was going to make you like me and now
i'm kind of you know people aren't going
to like me there are people who are
going to say oh that woman is a ditz or
that woman is annoying or too social or
whatever don't like my hair color i
don't know and that's okay not everybody
has to like me and i think the more
true to yourself you are about who you
want to be
it's okay if people don't like you
because if they don't like you
they're probably not the right people
for you anyway the issue is if you if
you have a persona that nobody likes you
know at some point that's kind of a
problem if you're off by yourself but
you know for me it's like you know my
style is definitely not does not work
for some people i'm not sure if you know
if i had been
if i had transplanted myself to new york
and tried to be in the
in the banking business
maybe it wouldn't have worked you know
maybe my style's just too laid back and
casual for
certain industries so that's why i ended
up being in this one
it seems from your case and what you've
been talking about today you've got
varying levels of contacts with your
friends and so some people you've seen
recently and always and then something
you probably haven't seen for a couple
years
i find it difficult myself and i'm
wondering if you have any tips or tricks
that you have to make it less
uncomfortable when you
reengage with people that you've either
forgotten or you know
you know they're nice people and you
know you want to be involved with them
and you see them after three or four
years you're like god i don't know your
name and i have completely forgotten all
about you yeah
do you have any tips really remembering
that or how to get through that initial
awfulness i mean the first thing is is
personally i almost never pick up the
phone it's all on email and if i'm gonna
talk to someone on the phone i schedule
a call
um because i find that the dialogue on
email allows you time to think it allows
you time to research it allows you a
different sort of flow of conversation
and it allows you to control the
interaction a little bit differently
than it does on phone now again please
temper that i do have friends they have
my cell phone number i have their cell
phone number we talk on the phone but
i'm saying in the context of what you're
saying like you run into someone and you
say gosh i haven't seen you in a couple
years
let i'll follow up with you on email
and then i follow up on email and i
figure out what the appropriate
um context is sometimes there's no
context sometimes
you know there's there's no reason to
get together sometimes you think well
that's a really interesting person and
even though there's no reason i want to
get together and you make time i also
think that um
i've gotten pretty good at at you know
for example
a friend of mine wrote a book about the
ipod a guy named steven levy writes for
newsweek and he asked me if i would have
a party at my house like a book signing
party so steve's based in
in new york and i said i'd have this
party for him and so
he and i collaborated on the guest list
and they've been what's been great about
that is there have been opportunities
for me to invite people that are not
necessarily people i'd have over to
dinner on friday night i haven't seen
them in a couple years but maybe they're
people i used to work with at apple or
they're people in the music industry or
there are people he and i know from you
know he used to be a reporter at mac
user
a kajillion years ago
that we know in common and it was a
great opportunity to reacquaint
uh those people you know to pull us all
together so they're going to be 80 or 90
people at the house and maybe 20 of
those people are people that i'd say hey
i haven't seen them in a couple years
there's context in this in this
how much time am i really going to spend
with each one of those people it's a
two-hour party and they're going to be
80 people at my house but
what's interesting about that and this
goes to this whole house thing which is
another contribution i i like to use my
house like a conference facility
but
people feel different when they come to
your house then they feel
if you run into them somewhere else they
feel like they have
that it's more personal and it is more
personal it's your house for god's sakes
you know so you do give up a little bit
of your you know um your whatever it is
your security or anonymity or whatever
when you have people over your house but
it means i can have a five minute
interaction with somebody that's
probably going to be more meaningful
than if i ran into them on the street
for five minutes but still there's only
you know i have the same issue you guys
all have there's only so many hours in a
day and at the end you got to figure out
who you spend time with because these
are either it's important to your work
or you just
enjoy it and you got to make trade-offs
and it's it's hard to do
can you talk about some bridges you've
burned or some contacts you've jacked up
yeah
i try to not burn any bridges but i
certainly have had some in the past that
you know there are people that i've
decided i'm not going to deal with you
anymore and again there's the subtle way
of just you know yeah we'll get together
someday oh i accidentally deleted your
email oh my spam filter must have caught
that email and you know
usually people kind of take the hint if
you're just unresponsive
that you eventually they go away and
and i take the hint if people are
unresponsive to me that i eventually go
away sometimes you have to specifically
say to someone you know what you did to
me is really wrong
and i don't like the way you behaved in
this manner and frankly our relationship
is over and i've probably done that
outside dating
i've probably done that
fewer than 10 times you know where i've
had to literally say to someone in fact
it's probably fewer than five times it's
probably like three or four times where
i've said to someone i just don't want
to hear from you anymore and usually
it's some really you know pretty bad
thing
in my life you wanted it to work out but
it didn't well i can tell you what i can
tell you one thing where i you know to
this day i feel bad about it there's
nothing more i can do about it but you
know somebody wrote this pretty nasty
book about steve jobs a number of years
ago and they quoted me extensively in
the book
and i knew the guy who wrote i knew the
guy and he had interviewed me
and
you know out of the things i said in the
book ten percent of the things are
probably things i said
that probably weren't that nice and i
wasn't being careful
and ninety percent are things there were
even really nice things i said that he
twisted around or didn't include or
whatever you know he had a picture he
wanted to paint and he used me
when the book came out i was completely
mortified and i thought what am i going
to do and what do you do i called steve
i apologized i said i'm really sorry
this happened you know the lesson to me
is some of those things i actually said
why would i do that you know but you
know whatever there were a few things i
said that weren't that nice there were
lots of nice things i said they didn't
include i said to steve you know i i
thought it was gonna be more balanced i
thought it was gonna be fair i'm really
sorry i did this i'm never doing it
again
and um
it was interesting i was somewhere with
his wife um laureen
last year at this time and and we were
away on this big hiking trip and finally
like on the friday the hiking trip i
said you know it just still really
bothers me and i just want you to know
i'm really i'm really sorry about it but
it's you know it's been like five years
and there's nothing i can't i can't undo
it right it'd happen and she's like
i can't believe you're even still
thinking about that you know which is it
she's like forget it you know it doesn't
matter it's you know we're all over that
but i think it's really interesting that
if you do something and it was wrong and
you value the person
you know
you apologize you do whatever you can to
make it right and you make sure it never
happens again and that's the best you
can do if they can if they still feel
that in their book that puts you in
you know as i call it with steve the
land of bozos forever then you're in the
land of bozos forever and you accept
that and you move on you know so
i don't know
try not to do it again
don't talk to the press
hi hi uh what's your most
fundamental motivation or drive i mean
what makes you tick
uh oh that's a great question i have no
idea
uh yeah i know what makes me i don't
know um
you know i'd say for a lot of my
entrepreneurial career was actually fear
of failure
um i didn't want to be a failure i
wanted to win i wanted there were people
who didn't think i could do it and i
really wanted to do it
and
i think that's kind of a negative
you know that's a little bit of this
beat the other team mentality but let's
face it it's really compelling to beat
the other team it's really compelling to
say
man those those vcs who turned me down
and those guys out of business school
told me i was nuts for starting my own
company i want to prove them wrong and
that does motivate you i think that some
of the motivation for me certainly in my
entrepreneurial days was the pride
of
seeing something great happen walking
down a street in taiwan and seeing my
product in the window or getting a great
review or seeing employees you know have
a have a have a great time i mean the
culture that we built at at our company
to this day
some of my best friends were the people
i worked with there and they'll say to
me i've never had a work experience like
that it was the best work experience
i've ever had so that drives me i mean
certainly the the financial rewards have
been great
certainly
the opportunity to contribute the
opportunity to give back to engage with
really interesting people
all those things are
you know it's interesting i don't think
i think about it every day i mean i am
still in my wage earning years and i
still do need to earn an income if i
want to live the lifestyle that i've now
accustomed myself to so i do have to
think about compensation i mean i don't
have the you know i don't have the
billion dollars in the bank and i can't
just stop doing that but i said to my
husband a couple days ago because i am
in a transition now where you know we're
not going to raise another fund and i'm
thinking about what's next for me i came
home from a board meeting and i said to
him i must just be twisted because i'd
rather spend a whole day
in a stuffy conference room
at a board meeting than like going to a
spa for the day i mean not every day but
we had a really great board meeting and
for me
a great board meeting with a lot of
interesting things going on where you
really go in and tackle problems and
contribute and try to help them recruit
someone and close a big deal
is more fun
than going to a spa for a day so i
i guess that's what works for me i don't
know
here
i'm reading the case and seeing you here
today talk about uh your life it's clear
you've been very successful in uh
building your career and touching many
lives um um in the valley and i think
many of us here are heading out to try
and do the same thing to build our own
brands and to touch lives and change
transitions and i'm sure in that journey
we won't all be successful all the time
right and i'm curious to hear your
perspective on how you've dealt with
setbacks and failures in your life thus
far and what we can take away from that
as we go forward
great question and and and clearly you
cannot be a venture capitalist in the
valley starting in 99 without having a
tremendous amount of failure so
i have a lot of failure that i can i can
draw upon to answer this
question um i think that
you know like probably all of you in
this room your successes have
outnumbered your failures and that's why
you're here and when you've had setbacks
you've had to you know come out and and
rise above them and certainly in my
career as an entrepreneur we certainly
had setbacks but somehow it all we
always you know i'd say it was sheer
tenacity and a great team that got me
through those and we ended up ultimately
turning in a success you know
sold the company our vcs made money we
made money we had a great time along the
way
um
then you know then i went to apple and i
think the biggest challenge i had at
apple was that i just couldn't fix it
you know i there was not i didn't have
the power or the skill set or the or the
resources or whatever it was i went
there and it was overwhelming to me and
after a year of being there i just said
this is not for me and i left
and i feel like i did a lot of good
things there but you know but again i
didn't take it as a personal failure i
was okay maybe i was still like coasting
on the ego of having and run my own
company i was still okay it was like
their fault not mine
maybe i don't know but then venture
capital was very challenging because of
course the first year i was a vc you
know my first two deals went public and
big returns and blah blah blah and then
the market crashed and i you know you go
from everything you everything you do is
gold into everything you do is crap
and you spend years digging out of it
and you start to have a real crisis of
confidence and say
am i wrong am i bad at this am i am i
just am i just stupid
um
and i thought about that a lot and and
when i had that crisis of confidence
what i said is
i believe there are things i'm really
good at and i believe there are things
i'm not good at
and in the things i'm not good at i
either have to decide to get good or i
have to build a career that plays on my
strengths and at that time i had a real
crisis of confidence my deals had all
fallen apart
and um i was lucky in that i had a
supportive partnership and i went to my
partners they wanted me to they like
they were like oh web services is hot
why don't you concentrate on web
services
and i thought about that and i struggled
and i looked at the market for six
months and i came back and i said
there's not a single deal i want to do
in web services and it might be because
i just think it's not a good market and
it might just be because i was a
creative writing major as an undergrad
you know web service is like a struggle
for me to study this stuff this is not
my
um this is not my thing
and so i decided
i was just going to play my strengths
and i said you know i really think that
i understand the consumer mentality and
and i also want to look at supply and
demand adventure and at the time in 2002
nobody was doing pre-revenue deals and
nobody was doing consumer deals and
nobody was doing ad-supported deals
because
well because there was a lot of you know
there was a lot of you know blood on the
pavement in the valley with all those
deals
and there was a lot of
kind of
momentum paralysis like unless you have
momentum i can't do the deal and so as
soon as you're a million a quarter in
revenues i'll look at you and i thought
well then i'm competing with all these
other vcs i don't want to do that so i
said i'm going to play my strengths and
i'm going to go where these other guys
aren't
and luckily my partners were like hey
that makes sense you know you should go
do that and as a result i did deals like
perpetual and ecast and reactrix that
you know that i that now you know again
they're not liquid yet so i don't want
to count them as victories until they
are victories but they all have had up
round financings this year they're all
doing really well
you know we'll see if it's a cyclical
market and we'll see if that works but i
think you know anytime you fail
i think that you know you need to you
need to
you need to mourn your failure you need
to understand why you failed and you
need to take whatever lesson you can
from that
and at a certain point you know like
laureen said to me you then need to move
on
and you then need to sort of say okay
i failed i invested a lot of money in a
bunch of things that ended up not
working
i can either go you know drown myself or
i can say well what did i learn from
those failures and go apply it what
strengths do i want to build where do i
want to focus my energies and so far
that's worked pretty well for me i mean
i think you know i think some failures
are harder to recover from than others
but um i do find that i cycle back as a
last point on that like i can agonize
over the same mistake for years
and i have found that you know you
almost have to it's like meditation you
almost have to say let go you know i
hear i hear what my mind is saying
yep
screwed that up let it go just walk away
from that and move on
when you first started your business
career what types of challenges did you
face just because you're a woman and how
many of those challenges do you think
still exist today i just think this goes
to that fundamental issue of playing
your strengths and understanding who you
are and
and i'm female that i was born that way
i'm gonna be that way and when i got to
business school here for example i said
okay
you know my class i don't know what
percentage you guys are we were like 23
were the women and i was interested in
technology which was at the time in 1981
to 83
not a lot of people came here wanting to
be in technology they mostly came to do
investment banking management consulting
and um and honestly i didn't even know
what those were when i got here so
um so you know somebody would come to
give a speech trip hawkins would come
give a speech and at the end there were
10 people who would hover around asking
him questions i was the only woman
tell you what my questions got answered
because i stood out and so
um i think that you know there is a line
between
using whatever attributes you have if
you're smarter you're a good singer or
you're this or that and exploiting your
difference and i think that you know you
got to be very careful and i think for
the women in the group there are some
things about you know i think the howard
heidi case tells you you are going to
get judged differently i mean i i do
know a lot of very high-powered women in
in many industries who get you know who
get characterized as a or
something you know where you think if a
guy did this nobody would
you know nobody would question why a guy
can raise his voice or or say swear
words in a meeting but if a woman says
it it's just completely different and so
you are judged differently
um i
i dress differently i don't put on a
business suit i don't play golf i don't
pee in a urinal there's all sorts of
things where i just don't i don't do
those things and so i do other things
you know maybe i cook pasta for
everybody maybe there are things that
work to my favor like like i said
earlier i think that the male ceos find
me less threatening which means they're
actually more comfortable telling me
when they're having issues and problems
and if i can help them solve those
issues and problems it's more likely the
company's going to be successful so i do
think there are certainly there have
certainly been times when i've walked
into a meeting and i've realized
there is no way
that i'm going to get funded or there is
no way that i'm going to get this bank
loan because i'm a woman that as soon as
they saw me walk in the door
it was over
and you can you can fight that and you
can do all that or you can just move on
because the the beauty and the glory of
entrepreneurship is
there's thousands of banks there's
thousands of vcs there's thousands of
people you can deal with and most of the
time your employees don't care that
you're a woman your customers don't care
that you're a woman
they care that your product's good they
care that your work environment's good
but actually most people don't care
there are some people who care and for
them there are replacements and that's
just you know
how it's worked for me and and you know
as a tell
point to this and a good ending point
it's something i think about a lot now
because i am now sort of being lumped in
with those career women who suddenly
don't do the high-powered jobs you know
people call me up some people have
called me up for ceo positions for very
high profile companies and i say i don't
want to do it
because
i don't want to do it it's because it's
just not that important to me to be on
the cover of a magazine or be a ceo or
or do that stuff anymore it's not worth
sacrificing my personal life anymore to
do those things and so i spend a lot of
time thinking about for the next phase
of my career because i still want to
have a career and be gainfully employed
and i like i said i like going to board
meetings better than spas so if you're
that twisted you better keep working
but
you're not going to see me suddenly take
a division vp job or or a general
manager of a big group or you you will
never see me
associated with a corporation at least
not while my children are still at home
because i'm just not willing to do that
and i kind of think
does that make me a bad statistic as a
woman you know am i suddenly a cop out
because i'm just yet another woman who's
going to be you know on the on the side
of the great you know i'm not going to
be on the cover of all these you know
whatever that magazine that does the 50
most powerful women i'm just not going
to be there
and is that a cop-out to all the people
who've invested in me to date and the
people hoping to raise the female flag
and say you know whatever or is it that
i'm so
enlightened and liberated that it's okay
to make that decision that you know i
can say yeah i could i could you know
one career path could have taken me that
way and i could have maybe done that but
i don't want to do it it's just not
important to me and it's okay
to decide you don't want to do that so
my closing comment to all you guys and i
think
you know
it's something i've tried to live you
know for my career is i try to do what i
actually enjoy doing because i think
people are just inherently better at
things that are personally fulfilling to
them that they enjoy doing that don't
compromise their ethics or their morals
and that allow them to work with people
they care about and enjoy working with
and if you're getting up every day and
you're not doing that
you should find something else to do
because most of your day you do spend
working i mean they're they're just
there you know and especially if you're
here you're probably already sort of
you've got that work bit so my sense of
that is
where i've come at this point at you
know 48.75 years or whatever is i'm just
unwilling
to
do those
to do those things that maybe look good
on a resume or get you on the cover of a
magazine but are counter to the way i
want to live my life
and
who knows if that's a good decision or
not but at least i'm kind of having fun
on a daily basis which
you know not to get too philosophical
here but you know that's pretty good
just in and of itself so anyway with
that
this was fun i'm sorry about last week
thank you